I've been preparing for my electoral
vote prediction that will be happening
tomorrow on the David Pakman show and I
want to talk through it with you because
I don't see any way that Donald Trump
can win the election tomorrow and I
don't know if I am just an idiot which
many of my viewers would agree with or
if I'm missing something but barring all
of the information we have being
completely wrong I don't see a path for
Donald Trump to win and we can sort of
talk through it right I mean when we
start with the base so if we look at any
polling website this is the
fivethirtyeight.com forecast and if we
just focus on if we start with just the
blue states where it's really looking
good for Hillary Clinton right so not
including North Carolina where there's a
54% chance of winning or Florida or even
Colorado New Mexico at over 80% going by
this map or the electoral - boat comm
map which is very very similar or even
the 270 to win calm state polls if we
start with just Hillary Clinton's base
we start with Vermont and New York and
Massachusetts and Rhode Island and
Pennsylvania and Connecticut and New
Jersey and Delaware Maryland DC of
course Minnesota as well as Wisconsin
are going to go for Hillary Clinton
Michigan although Trump is talking about
it every indication it will go for
Hillary Clinton Illinois will absolutely
go for Hillary Clinton and then you have
the west coast which it's just it's
going for Hillary as well as Hawaii you
start to see very very quickly that
Hillary Clinton's base is really really
looking quite solid here and then of
course we have to really I believe add
Virginia they're a state where Donald
Trump has pulled resources and has left
so as you can see Hillary
than is starting with 251 electoral
votes leaving her 19 shy of the number
needed to win 270 so it out if North
Carolina Carolina ends up going her way
and New Hampshire Hillary Clinton wins
if instead it is Florida that goes her
way she wins if instead of Florida it is
you know Maine which will very very
likely go for Hillary Clinton and we
haven't even touched over here where
Colorado is likely to go for Hillary
Clinton New Mexico is likely to go for
Hillary Clinton in this scenario you're
looking at now which doesn't include New
Hampshire it doesn't include North
Carolina and it doesn't include Florida
she has the magic number to at least
prevent Donald Trump from from winning
right to 69 would be exactly half of the
electoral votes this is a very very
conservative scenario for Hillary
Clinton let's reset the map and and go
blank
again let's look at Donald Trump's base
and this is roughly an order of closing
time he is going to get West Virginia
he's going to get South Carolina
he will get Georgia even though we've
been talking about it as maybe future
swing state Alabama and Mississippi and
Tennessee are going to go in trumps
direction Kentucky is one of the early
closing ones that will go for him
Indiana as well as an Azeri Arkansas
Louisiana will go for Trump the Dakotas
will go for Trump Nebraska will go for
Trump Kansas and Oklahoma will go for
Trump Texas will the turn Texas blue
project not yet there where it will make
a difference electoral Lee this election
Montana and Wyoming certainly will go
for Trump as well as Idaho Arizona is
probably going for Trump and Utah even
though there's been a lot of talk about
Evan McMullen I believe will ultimately
go for Donald Trump and certainly Alaska
will as well so now is where it really
starts to get difficult for Donald Trump
because as you can see what possible
States could Donald Trump win here well
if we look at the election forecast
Arizona is about a 70% for Trump and we
have that already in his corner if you
look at Nevada 56 to 44 for Hillary
Clinton according to 538 slightly in
Trump's favor
according to electoral vote calm and
according to the five 272 win you will
see that it is basically slightly in
favor of Trump's so let's give it to him
right let's give him Nevada let's also
give them Iowa because if you look at
Iowa 7230 Trump right not this 80%
threshold I use to establish Hillary
Clinton's base let's give them I awoke I
because if we give Ohio to Trump and
Ohio is one where it's about a two to
one in favor of Trump right now
according to 538 electoral vote comm has
Trump ahead but within the margin of
error and 272 wyndcomm has Trump ahead
slightly in Ohio
let's give him Ohio we're only at 221
right now so what's next what else could
Donald Trump win well let's give him
Florida as well and you'll see that that
gets Donald Trump to 250 and here's
where it really gets difficult for Trump
let's give him North Carolina as well
let's give them every single one of
these states and you will see that there
is a very difficult path forward for
Donald Trump here you would have to
imagine the most Trump a favorable
scenario that you can imagine even if we
then give him New Hampshire as well
right this is basically every swing
state going to Donald Trump the best
that he could hope to do is merely to
tie Hillary Clinton and as you will see
as we start to fill in the map in favor
of Hillary Clinton it is very very
difficult to imagine any of these going
in the direction of Donald Trump if I'm
missing a particular state that could go
in a different direction let me know and
as you can see if we instead of starting
blank we started this deadlocked
scenario make the case for me that one
of these
red states will not go for Hillary
Clinton of course if North Carolina goes
for Hillary Clinton then Hillary Clinton
wins I mean that is that is just it's
just the math of it and there's really
no way no way around that if instead of
North Carolina up Florida were to go for
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton wins
let's put that back to trump if Ohio
were to go for Hillary Clinton not
particularly likely but then Hillary
Clinton wins and in this scenario which
is a hugely generous scenario for Trump
even if just little New Hampshire were
prizes just watching President Obama
speak in New Hampshire even in that
scenario if New Hampshire goes for
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton wins I
believe a more likely scenario would be
something like what you are looking at
now 317 to 221 and that may ultimately
be my prediction tomorrow if we look at
Florida 54 to 46 chance of winning
favoring Hillary Clinton according to
538 Hillary Clinton +2 according to
ellic total vote calm and Florida
currently on 270 to wind calm tide so
Florida is one that Trump absolutely
needs Hillary Clinton would take it
Hillary Clinton could use it but it is
not even necessary as you can see here
even with Ohio and Florida for Donald
Trump Hillary Clinton still winning tell
me where I'm wrong and if you're just
saying hey the momentum is with Trump we
are not going to get drastically
different poll numbers from tonight to
tomorrow and remember that 30 to 40
percent of the votes have already been
cast what states specifically is it that
Trump would take let's look you know
Pennsylvania is another one that people
are talking about this scenario that
you're looking at here if Trump can win
Ohio and Pennsylvania and Florida that
would get him to 270 Pennsylvania is not
looking good three two one shot for
Hillary Clinton
according to 538 electoral - boat comm
has Clinton plus five and according to
272 win
dot-com Pennsylvania plus five as well
for Donald Trump tell me what you think
where am I going wrong here